[Music]
look sharp anywhere you want another son
Jim yeah how'd it go there was a it was
great man I love talking to my bullet
tree Hampi yeah yeah he's a good guy
yeah what's one with you now first time
yeah
pleasure yeah they far there's so many
categories we can go down right and
that's what's you know I would argue the
biggest thing you guys should be
thinking about is tripling down on how
you got here something I've been
thinking about you your bro and other
like the kind of top 10 is everybody's
now in a mad dash to monetize as they
should these are remarkably big numbers
I just don't think you're going away and
if you're not going away my big thing
now more than ever is how do you go way
more back to the consumer the youth like
I think if I heard today that you're
doing a two-hour Q&A live stream every
single day with your fans like juice
with Jake and it's like literally like
just drinking apple juice in the morning
like it's a different juice every
morning you know and just two hours like
like real real not even on an
entertainment kick just like [ __ ] GMA
even maybe it's weird that I bring this
up when you just went on the old version
of it and just like how you doing cool
Sarah thank you for that yeah I do
remember like just real like as if you
were like with 20 kids that like I've
loved you've read it oh [ __ ] I forgot
about that [ __ ] post or like oh you
what has happened to like Sally Pants 49
she did have 30 million she's doing well
to me like what I'm feeling right now is
this is the moment more than ever to
unmonitored rupal down that audience
right while it's underpriced while it's
underpriced attention get as much as you
can because the monetizing can be done
at any point and I just think everyone's
like you know again having empathy when
you're young you're on the ride there's
a lot
like the the insecurities change and
securities drive so much the insecurity
now is can I be a professional and drive
and build an empire and be a businessman
or woman at that level you know what I
mean it's fun to watch so I think it's a
very special interesting time for you
where that's just one thing I would give
a lot of thought to the audience has to
be the fourth pillar or it needs to be a
separate thing if Leo is that then the
Scarecrow let's build out Wizard of Oz
here you got the [ __ ] lion cool let's
like the Scarecrow neat or Dorothy needs
to be the audience right if you guys are
the Cowardly Lion with your strategy
like Dorothy needs to be the audience
like I don't know this is like honestly
I'm giving myself advices I'm talking to
you like this is always the religion and
it's an interesting time yeah because
you become you bro you be common the
next you become the next Brad Pitt Leia
be it this is how it happens yeah like
like if you're 13 right now you're the
establishment and that new person that
popped last week is you yeah it's just
you wake up and it is it's funny to
think big launch on Twitch I think
you're gonna see in the next year a big
game we've been on it forever like we
like life-size you saw what happened
last night last night was the moment of
changed I've been like we're putting
together a video right now I'm glad to
see you're not doing it that means
bobbins making a good one right iris
sat all right Seth Seth you better not
[ __ ] up this video you're doing the
twitch video
you better [ __ ] annihilate it it's
just all this is what's great about foam
can film yourself
it's [ __ ] me in 20 14 15 16 17
talking about twitch and then I gave and
then I made I literally land at 4:30
somewhere I'm like all right it happened
last night the crossover a moment here
come here comes people then ask me what
I think about it here's what I think
about it and I'm just gonna be [ __ ]
like two minutes of highlights of me
being like twitch [ __ ] like just like
that's what I trade on right like that's
what's good about kind of how I do what
I do look the world is your [ __ ]
waster no matter all the dumb [ __ ] that
happens along the way over the next five
years as long as it's not super
egregious you'll you'll get through that
funnel easily what where you'll get
caught way more than like burning down a
house or you know whatever somebody
getting hurt on a prank or something or
some of these feelings getting hurt
where you'll loses you'll you'll be a
boa constrictor that tries to eat an
elephant and you'll blow up that's
exactly what happen together you rats
you need to be eat you need to eat like
hippos right like but Boas are amazing
but they some you know those [ __ ] you
know I'm insured there's videos online
where they write they try to eat
something too big and they break and
they're amazing they can eat big-ass
[ __ ] and you're amazing you're gonna be
able to eat big-ass [ __ ] you just need
to be very thoughtful that you don't try
to eat too much which then blows you up
I'm with you man gaming well you could
talk about gaming crypto VRA are merch
food retail stores what in a few minutes
you're gonna realize that [ __ ] you
and your bro are basically the
Wahlberg's and like let's go after
McDonald's I mean like this is all real
my point of view take a good [ __ ]
week and go to [ __ ] like Turks and
Caicos or Hawaii and don't produce
content and just [ __ ] think
and then really come to like what is the
most exciting thing we could do and
let's just spend one year dismantling
that wall in parallel crushing audience
growth and all this other [ __ ] will be
there forever merch is never gonna go
away
endorsement deals are gonna only get
bigger it's all coming it's a it's
taking a step back and taking a breath
and realizing it won't go away
especially if number one 2 & 3 is the
audience
amazing job of recirculating the old
concept yes all yes my brother I know
dude by the way what the I think we
really are the best at it right now when
I look and we're not even like good at
it that's how good it is talking to
yourself you remember it was funny with
Logan in the parrot and you know when I
came to you I was like the cartoon kid
that you guys just added to the team ten
actually dude that we probably had that
video cuz we filmed that day when I came
to team ten right well no I was a
blogger yet oh [ __ ] but you remember
right I literally said them like make a
cartoon I believed in it more than ever
now because of snapchats new AR kit I
think the number one thing you should do
number one cuz Walt Disney built a much
bigger company than [ __ ] Vince McMahon
I'm creating a character like in a world
of them you need to go hard at it good
on the content side there's massive play
I think it's bigger than everything and
then I think the game show side I think
there's like bro I couldn't agree more
head audience it's the only thing that
matters think about all the things we
just mentioned that weren't even
emerging a year ago like twenty truly
twenty four months ago back to animated
we wouldn't be talking about use an
animation and [ __ ] game show right if
we're sitting here 24 months ago neither
one of those things come out of any of
our mouths my big thing right now is
when you're the king of the hill triple
down on it more well I would go back to
Jake Paul 0.1 where it was just about
the audience like as much as you can and
I know you can't go all the way back I
get it I get it but if I can get you 70%
fat of that 30% of what you're actually
doing now your hope your whole world
will be different audiences know just so
you know they will never be tricked
either you're doing it for them or
you're doing it for yourself when you
audit your [ __ ] last three weeks and
you think about how many hours you spent
on what's for you what's for them it
doesn't look pretty and it doesn't look
pretty for any of the a-list right now
in our world so cool and I driven by the
right thing I get
you did that first you're trying to make
your name and the next thing I get it
but I'm telling you that's where the
secret is cool that if you guys agree
with that and like like you can't
imagine how excited I am right now cuz I
actually think you guys are super smart
like I think you might agree and you
might do something about it and you're
gonna be like a genuinely think I'm
gonna get like a text from your video
like in four weeks and be like dude
because what's gonna happen cuz you're
so good and you're so big and you're so
creative and you're gonna if you give a
[ __ ] it's just gonna compound I don't
know you know we know ya know it's just
gonna work I know I watched music twitch
and quadrupled dowing on the other
things yeah
music twitch and cook tripled out like
like I can't imagine where your Twitter
and Facebook game are but I know they're
not good enough yeah because because
there's no reason just you just found
just film I'm just [ __ ] filming bro
he's so creative like [ __ ] just felt
you should 24 hours a day I have
somebody following you here's why you're
gonna say something smart or creative or
funny or when you really get to it when
you really get smart in my opinion when
you're there with Strahan and you guys
have a little clip in the greenroom and
then you clip it and you run in a
facebook against [ __ ] giant fans from
nine who are 42 years old who love
Strahan there's a segmentation right now
on Facebook that are giant fans that are
the age when he played and fans of Good
Morning America they're both there's
18,000 people 180,000 people you take
that clip and you post it and he siphons
8% fans paid collapse yeah by the way
you know we hear that and like what
happens when you're this size is you
don't use paid media because it's all
organic
meanwhile the paid media is never been
so my question becomes like here's
what's gonna happen I'm gonna end up
becoming the most famous of everybody
because I'm committed just to audience
and even though I started further behind
and not in the perfect zone I can just
I'm just watching it happen
Instagram podcast is huge for me man I
think you should have a top 100 podcast
tomorrow nobody in really your world has
done that and like Facebook is huge
email you should sue you wanna see
something cool look what the [ __ ] these
guys are doing [ __ ] this you could
annihilate here's what I'm sensing the
worst part of internet marketing is
starting to bleed into the influencer
space it's not gonna become spammy CDs
in the back but it's gonna become some
sort of thing and I think the ones that
can rise above it and do what I did
during the 2000s and stay above that
fray are the ones that are gonna win the
most and right now everybody's on tilt
of monetization without really proper
thought around what that means because
when you make that switch the audience
relationship changes and you become more
than you know you become more and
because your relationship is only about
the transactional business and the
authenticity and uniqueness of what you
were built on and why you were able to
win that game goes away
selling out it's not super complicated
it yeah I mean listen I mean I was in
like the prime of my business life I
just invested in Twitter and Facebook
and Tumblr and made all that you know it
was all coming up they were all going
public this was a grind man like
building the agency sucks like I have a
real job
like I'd like as where like I've people
that a lot of people answer to I'm like
answering to them I was on to client
calls the second I landed this morning
this is me giving you advice based on
actually something I'm doing which is
built for the long-term
what do you what do you focus on next
building out looking cat is there a
category you want to go out here is
there anything that anything that
matters right like like that whole area
you know we've like we're turning into a
to twitch studio sites right here like
we made that decision after I went on a
Twitter show with Hunter Pence the
baseball player like a couple of months
ago and like I said I saw some wife
doing it like yourself yeah like you
coming through right now I'm gonna take
five minutes and play the but I'm gonna
make it authentic right like I don't
play the new [ __ ] so cool like you and I
are gonna play like Madden 94 cuz that's
what I know you know it's like all these
kids I got like I'm gonna try to like
play the three games I'm good at and
then let them like me like cool that let
me show you your mother thing they'll
kill me in two seconds of my [ __ ] a lot
a lot I mean that's where Facebook I
think you should go all in on it you can
reach audience International we're
running some ads right now in India
it's [ __ ] nuts I also claimed that
I'm gonna make myself the most famous
person in Peru just on ads on Facebook
with my content I'm gonna do it for like
six months and you just fly to prove and
see what happens I think it's gonna be
crazy like that's the kind of stuff I
think he should be doing right that's
that's where that's that's where Jerome
was very smart like when I would tell it
like he when I would like feed him this
he would run with it and get it he
really he was a good he was a good
understood like he had all his natural
skills but then like when I would be
like do this he would understand
remember I was like he was I was like go
to globe globe remember when he went
like Mexico and everywhere I go global
and go collab with everybody you've all
the leverage the universe in here's what
I think about with global if I was a
partner in this team I'm like it's all
about audience audience matters global
matters so time is our biggest issue
right opportunity costs [ __ ] it let's
sit down let's do the math who is the
biggest [ __ ] 10 influencers in Brazil
got it but but you do a month a month
when you make a thoughtful plan to go to
India for four days and you actually
allocate every minute properly and you
actually systematically cross every T
and I like it's all about efficiency
like we'll take this highway we're gonna
stop right here or
I'd hit up you know honi he's gonna meet
us there we'll do the collab there and
like it's literally just about sex in a
real way you know what I mean can I can
I can I tell you something audience
you're only as good as how big that
bucket is you're upside is not gonna be
stopped by creativity or opportunity
it's gonna be based it's gonna be
stopped by audience you got to tap out
cuz you've got your bucket it's one of
the biggest buckets in the world right
now but if you're not filling it up
every time you're doing [ __ ]
you're squeezing it out that's what
happens to everybody your training on
Fame got it that's the game a lot more
for them lot more for them because right
now you you did a lot for them and it's
all about being cashed out you're just
doing you're just doing stuff for
audience and you let them weave in and
out I don't think about it actually I'm
just doing the best work I can do that I
think brings people value and let that
Mebane flow don't overthink that and
you're gonna change right you're also in
a interesting time of your life like
when you're in your 20s or early 20 you
know bobbing as a man so you're gonna
they're gonna you know things are gonna
happen
I mean happen to be hardcore when I
switched from wine to business content
like hey wine boys stay in your lane was
very common yeah you know cool it's
peanut bounce
welcome good to see you doing it well my
man
[Music]